[Musique] La
Chine veut venir vivre avec moi pour
le reste de sa dernière année ou elle
veut venir vivre avec toi tu as un
appartement géant et tu as les Hamptons et
la plaine rien de tout ça n'est de ma faute tu
m'as divorcé alors que je  était un perdant alors tu as
perdu pouvons-nous obtenir le chèque
passez-vous un bon moment laissez-moi y
réfléchir et ensuite nous en reparlerons plus tard d'accord
je t'aime aussi as-tu pensé
à ce que tu vas faire de ta
vie je  je ne connais pas bien papa on en reparlera
d'accord d'accord je t'aime je t'aime
une fille de cet âge a des ennuis
et si elle aime son papa ça veut dire que
tu ne fais rien c'est que ta
copine
oh mon dieu non c'est ma  fille Chyna oh
wow elle est magnifique
[Musique]
c'est Leslie bien j'ai voulu le
rencontrer toute ma vie
je serai le meilleur cinéaste des 30 dernières
années ou plus d'accord eh bien il sort aussi avec de
très jeunes femmes et il a environ 80
ans  vieux je suis Leslie salut vous licenciez
votre actrice principale et embauchez une
star de cinéma enceinte je suis sor  ry c'est ce
qu'on appelle quatre appels pour m'acheter qui l'
homme prend en charge Ralph
avec Lesley Goodwin je ne suis pas bizarre ce n'est
pas si bizarre il aime les jeunes filles oui
il aime la
Chine c'est une enfant elle ne sait rien elle est
comme une princesse Disney sous oestrogènes  elle
pourrait faire bien pire c'est ma fille La
Chine est mineure
[Musique]
Je veux dire tout le monde est un pervers